so jumping right into the brother's son
um what is it about like the action
genre that is so appealing to you like
and then this project in turn ah you
know with the action genre you get to do
crazy things that you won't do in life
normally right who runs around being
chased by like seven brutes and then you
get to fight them off and them out of
this this out the window uh so I find
that very challenging physically and
mentally very challenging but of course
like like all action sequences there
must be drama behind it the reason for
fighting it's like is it for defensive
is it uh offensive is it uh just to play
and tease the other person so it's very
important to set the tone and um what
appealed to me was in brother's son was
this incredible high octane um
choreography of action sequences where
it is peppered with so much humor and
some of them you go oh my God I can't
even believe they thought of that you
know it's like in the spa scene some of
the action sequences and they're so well
done and so well choreographed I'm so
proud of Justin our sun team our son
coordinators um who put it all together
and even Sam Sam song you know when he
runs around to pretend he doesn't know
what he's doing he knows to he has to
know exactly what he's doing to be able
to create that kind of humor and a
scenario where the two of them fight
with people who are trying to kill them
the whole time so it's like um it's it's
almost like a buster Kon Jackie Chan
things that we love and we've seen but
not in this context before uh and then
kicking up a few notches where we
literally have heads and body parts
flying around so what in making the show
would you say was your biggest challenge
oh keeping a straight face
Maybe
now I had such a good time working with
uh you know Brad and Byron and Kevin and
yet new they brought together especially
Brad and Byron they brought together an
amazing cast uh of uh from Asia from
Europe from America and to tell such a
crazy ass story about it can be very
very dark and what appealed to me was
such a dark kind of story could be told
in such a way where at the end of the
day it's family it's love it's about
sacrifice and very important about
forgiveness and coming back together
again uh that was the the real basis of
this this series and that really really
appealed to me of this immigrant family
who a mother who had to make such
horrible choices at the beginning uh to
get to where she is today so it was was
uh based on that and when I read the
script I was like this could be a lot of
fun because even then you can see all
these things popping out at you and you
go like oh that would be amazing to see
how they can achieve that and I think we
did I am so proud of our our series The
brother's son I love the the way the
show kind of strikes the balance between
like what a mother wouldn't do for her
kids but also like what she wouldn't do
for herself right as well and how how
she needs to kind of
that's mother she want that's a mother's
job right it's like sometimes the
thankless job but you know they do it
not because they want a thank you from
you they do it because they feel I
brought you into this world I have a
great responsibility towards you your
your life and your future as well being
a mother just never stops I mean even
when you're married and have kids on
your own they're still your mother never
stop being that I was curious like just
for fun which of your other iconic
characters do you think would get along
best with Mama son oh God I think uh oh
I think none of the other e would get
along they live in such such different
worlds and I think that is one thing I
do take such care in doing is like I
want to portray even though it's a
mother but how am I different in every
single one I would like to be able to
only uh to portray characters Poss
possibly that I've not done before or
not in a a style or genre that it's been
seen before and so that's why the
brother son was very exciting for me you
know to be a mama Crime Boss and then to
come out here and pretend to be an
ordinary mom with you know the brains
and skill of being able to wipe out if
she wanted to hold gangs so um it it
gives you a sense of a challenge I think
that's what I look uh for forward to
because when you're passionate about
something you don't just sit back and do
the norm you need to be challenged you
need to find something the nuances or
something new and with this I was
challenged every day by you know uh my
my sons you know by the young people
like uh TK and Alice and Jenny and you
know all of them brought such nuances to
their characters and to the way they
worked I'm so proud of them and so proud
to be a part of their family as well I
have to ask a very selfish question
because a lot of us at collider are Star
Trek fans so I just wanted to ask like
just we are all such fans so I wanted to
ask if you had updates on section 31
when you're gonna start filming do you
know anything like that I just came I
just came back from Toronto and what
does that tell you we had definitely
prepping we are definitely going full
steam ahead and thank you this this
section 31 is very special to me and I'm
so happy we're doing it I can't I can't
wait I love that whole side of the plot
so I'm very very excited for it thank
you
so as I wrap up I want to know what is
it about the brother son that you were
most excited for people to experience
when the series come I think um this
really is a journey about an immigrant
mother who had to make terrible hard
choices but at the end of the day when
they got to Los Angeles and the the
world literally erupts in chaos
and violence and body parts uh it's also
coming to terms with we have to deal
with it as a family we have to learn to
love each other sacrifice for each other
but most important forgive each other
then only you can move forwards and what
I've really found really exciting to
work with is given the opportunity to do
such a crazy ass series it's really fun
Michelle thank you so so much I loved
the series I'm excited to like share it
with my mom because I think she's going
to like it she's G to freak
out thank you thank
you